coming into the playing hall and making
your opponents stand up to shake hands
and uh that's what we're seeing yeah
then we're seeing uh magnus is the one
bright and early to the board
kind of ceremonial make uh move maker
i think that is a sign because he then
adjusted the queen's pawn okay and it
was quite a
confident adjustment moment of truth
which pawn has he pushed it does look
like d4
queens four queens porn okay so so far
i'm
okay with my prediction okay the night
has come out okay this is what napoli
actually does nearly 100 of the time
against 1d4 against the queen's pawn
magnus there taking more control of the
center with pawns will we see
okay it's not a grandfather of anchor i
think your prediction wasn't quite right
there unfortunately
um it looks like he's pushed his e pawn
so will we see a nimzo indian defense
will we see a transposition to the
queen's gambit oh and now this is the
thing i okay pawn comes up okay so we
still have a lot of choices
and it's a transposition to the queen
scan but declined and ivanka you
mentioned this a couple of hours ago
this is the opening that's called the
catalan
prediction it's nearly spot-on not quite
this time but you know i was too too
late with my
corrective guess okay so napoleon
following the pattern that he's done
before i mean he's played this against
anish giri quite recently in croatia
and uh yeah this is the main line of
what we call the catalan opening and the
catalan opening
is kind of shown once white develops his
bishop to this square white's light
squared bishop just sliding across to
the longest possible diagonal this is
still main line theory we'll explain
some of the ideas
behind both sides openings a bit later
on meanwhile black is the first to
castle and white follows suit so both
kings super safe we